il fêtera son 100e anniversaire dans un
an le golf le saint germain est implanté
dans la forêt depuis 1922 sur
d'anciennes terres agricoles le parcours
a été dessiné par l'un des meilleurs
architectes de l'époque harry colts le
britannique inconscient un parcours
forestier reconnu dans le monde entier
avec notamment 116 bon coeur à saint
germain est considérée suis en suivant
leur propre foyer le mot anglais au
ranking parmi les dix plus beaux
parcours de l'europe continentale pour
certains dans les cinq parcours d'europe
continentale mais c'est sûrement le
parcours le le plus célèbre et le plus
ancien d'ibm
le parcours évinois organisé neuf open
de france dont le dernier en 1985 avec
la victoire de severiano ballesteros les
greens ont en plus accueilli la légende
ben hogan le célèbre golfeur au 64
victoires sur le tour américain des
personnalités prestigieuses sont
également venus assange à mansle et à
partir de 1945 saint germain et l état
major de l'armée américaine
et nous avons reçu ici notamment le
général eisenhower le général des
misères mais surtout le général than
hour nous avons aussi reçu ici de duc de
windsor qui venait régulièrement jouer
au golf de la propriété qu'il avait en
bordure du bois de boulogne
aujourd'hui le golf associatif reçoit
régulièrement des professionnels ils
organisent des tournois et notamment des
championnats de france la structure
compte près de mille adeptes le plus
jeune à trois ans et le plus ancien 96
ans au delà de la compétition ce club
familial prône avant tout un style de
vie est membre d'un club comme saint
germain c'est accepter le cédait cdh et
membre d'un club à la britannique c'est
à dire vivre comme seul pour son club
accepter les différentes compétitions
qui sont là et retrouver des amis et de
ne pas venir uniquement taper des balles
et en partir après une partie pour
rejoindre ce club historique il faut
être parrainé par deux membres les
admissions lieu deux fois par
[Musique]
et